- Okay.
- [Mark] All right, Sweet Pea.
Sweet Pea, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up originally?
- Culver City (mumbles).
- [Mark] LA?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood,
you had both your parents growing up?
- No.
I was raised by my grandma,
and then when she died
I was raised by my aunt.
- [Mark] What happened to mom and dad?
- My mom was on the street homeless
and my father wasn't in the picture.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- It was all right.
Spoiled.
Got to go to Disney and all
those places growing up.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] No traumatic events, no abuse?
- Just standard sitting in
the corner that's about it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What kind of kid were you in high school?
- Say that again.
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in high school?
- I was always to myself,
so I was like a tomboy-ish.
- [Mark] Were you popular or you were--
- No, I wasn't popular.
- [Mark] And then at what point did you,
what age did you leave home?
- I didn't leave home till I was 18.
- [Mark] Where'd you go?
- I was in Arizona.
- [Mark] And when did you
start working as a prostitute?
- Two weeks ago.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
Oh, so this is new for you?
Let's back up--
- It's not really new.
I just upgraded, I guess. I don't know.
It's my first time for having a pimp.
- [Mark] So,
what have you been doing
up until two weeks ago?
Living on the street?
- Living life, I guess, yeah.
Dealing with dramatic people,
immature people.
- [Mark] Yeah, drugs are
part of your life, right?
- Yeah, fentanyl.
And crystal.
- [Mark] You smoking
fentanyl and crystal meth?
How long has that been going on?
- The crystal has been going
on for the last couple of years
since 2018.
And then the Fetty
since last year October.
- [Mark] And money got tight,
and you realized you
could make more money?
- No, 'cause I always got it for free.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
What helped you make the decision
to work with a pimp now?
- A financial advisor, whatever.
- [Mark] So he helps with your money?
- [Sweet Pea] Yeah.
- [Mark] How much of your
money do you give him?
- [Sweet Pea] I give him all my money.
- [Mark] What is he doing with it?
- [Sweet Pea] He puts it into
like the rent and then he
puts into whatever we need.
- [Mark] So, he'll help you find guys?
Or how do you guys find business?
- [Sweet Pea] I walk the track.
- [Mark] Figueroa Street?
- [Sweet Pea] No.
- What streets do you work?
- [Sweet Pea] Sepulveda.
- [Mark] Up to the Valley?
So two weeks into it.
How do you...
First two weeks gone?
- [Sweet Pea] All right.
- [Mark] Are you liking it?
Are you adjusting to it?
Are you--
- [Sweet Pea] I'm adjusting to it.
- [Mark] What's the hardest part?
- [Sweet Pea] Just finding the dates,
avoiding police, I guess.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I mean, you realize it's
a dangerous lifestyle
and all that, right?
- [Sweet Pea] It is.
But it's a different experience.
- [Mark] That's for sure.
I mean, there's a chance
of you getting arrested.
There's a chance of you getting beaten up
all that kind of stuff.
- True.
But as long as we know what we need to do,
none of that will happen.
- [Mark] How much money
are you making a night?
- It depends.
- [Mark] You're okay with
giving away your money
and hoping that it's
gonna come back one day?
Or if you need it'll be...
- Whatever I need, he gets it for me.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] What's to keep you
from doing it by yourself?
Without them.
- I wouldn't be doing it at
all if I didn't have my pimp.
Or my daddy.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- Yeah, I have two.
- [Mark] And where are they?
- With my adopted mom, my aunt in Arizona.
- [Mark] Do you talk to them?
So you basically just
kind of living on your own
with your pimp?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] I mean, so you're
living on the street
or you're in hotels or?
- No, we live in a hotel.
So, I live with him, my daddy.
- [Mark] Yeah.
You think you're happy?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You okay with this life?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Do you have any
plans for your future?
- Hopefully I get my girls back.
- [Mark] How old are they?
- 10 and three.
- [Mark] (mumbles) the drugs
will be a hard thing to kick?
- No, I could do it.
I just choose not to do it.
- [Mark] What's stopping you
from getting clean and getting
back together with your kids
and being a mom?
- Nothing. Just myself, I guess.
- [Mark] Do you think
it's something that...
Do you think it's some kind
of self-worth issue or,
what do you think the
biggest block is for you
in doing that?
'Cause what you're doing
now is certainly not
a lifestyle that is good
for your kids or for you.
- Well, my family doesn't
know about what I'm doing.
And my girls are too
young to know what this is
and I wouldn't let them do
this when they get older.
- [Mark] What do you think
the most misunderstood thing
about drug addiction and
sex work is for people
that don't do it?
- Everybody's answer is different.
Making money is making money.
At the end of the day you look at it.
- [Mark] When did you first
get introduced to drugs?
- When I was,
it's funny, three.
But I didn't start doing it till I was 24.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- 30.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- Growing up.
Not having to worry
about doing, paying bills
or paying rent or anything like that.
- [Mark] And what was the
roughest part of your life?
- Losing family members.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- Losing family.
- [Mark] Losing family.
Do you think you're addicted to this life?
This, the street, drugs, sex work life?
- No.
- [Mark] No?
You can walk away tomorrow?
- If I could, yeah.
- [Mark] Have you had
relationships before?
You've been married?
- Never married.
- [Mark] You've been in love?
- I mean, I'm in love with my pimp.
I do love him.
- [Mark] How'd you meet him?
- I met him through a mutual friend.
So I got our friend to thank
for meeting each other,
so yeah.
- [Mark] How long have you known him?
- A couple of weeks now, almost a month.
We've known each other
for like a couple of
weeks and almost a month.
About a month.
But I barely started
working for him two weeks.
- [Mark] He's got you working
for him having sex with guys
and that works for you
in your relationship?
- It makes money for us.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] Can you imagine
a relationship where,
maybe your partner is more
supportive and helps you or,
more concerned about your
safety or your future?
- And I know he's
concerned about my safety.
That's why before I get a date,
I always text him dollar signs
and then I let him know
that I'ma be on my way back.
Just take care of business,
get the money and come back.
That's it.
I'm not in danger.
I'm safe.
And I'm in good hands.
- [Mark] The relationships
you had with men before him
how were those relationships?
- Abusive.
- [Mark] Abusive.
- They didn't give two fucks
about me at the end of the day.
- [Mark] Do you see that maybe
there's something that you're doing,
or decisions you're making
that might be leading to that?
- Getting abused?
- [Mark] Or just getting
into relationships
that are abusive.
Do you think it's just bad luck?
Or do you think there's
something you're doing
that's creating that?
- It's just being with somebody
that's their heads feel like,
'cause they're in the drug
club they're in the cloud.
So,
all their mind is about just dope,
and what they can get out of it.
- [Mark] And do you
take any responsibility
for getting into those situations
or you just think it's just,
you meet a bunch of jerks?
- I just happened to
meet a lot of assholes.
- [Mark] Do you have
any goals for your life?
- If I could get my girls back.
- [Mark] Other than your kids?
I mean like your career or
anything you'd love to do?
- Go back to school.
- [Mark] Did you finish high school?
- No.
- [Mark] How far did you get?
- 11th grade.
I've been on my own since I was 18.
- [Mark] You've been arrested before?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] For drugs?
- No.
Other things.
- [Mark] Does your pimp have plans
of like maybe taking you to Las Vegas or
other areas like that to make more money?
- We're not
on that subject yet
but when it comes to it,
I don't know.
- [Mark] And the guys you pick up,
you guys would go to a
motel or go to the car
or where do you guys do business?
- The car or sometimes we use the room.
- [Mark] How much money
do you make typically?
- If it's a good day
may go to 500 sometimes.
Although, if it's a bad
day, slow day maybe,
like last night I made like 350.
- [Mark] And how much do you
spend on meth and fentanyl
a day?
- Don't spend that much.
So I don't have to buy it
'cause he provides it for me.
- [Mark] If something could be different
about your life today,
what would you want that to be?
- Nothing good, I'm happy where
I'm at and what I'm doing.
- [Mark] What do you think about,
I mean, if your parents
were in your life as a kid,
do you think you'd be in
a different place today?
- It's hard to say.
- [Mark] What lessons have
you learned in your life?
- A lot.
I don't know.
- [Mark] Is there anything in your life
that you're passionate about?
- Well, I want to go to
school and become a mechanic,
but yeah, right now my line of work is
hoeing, prostituting.
- [Mark] What would
you say to your family,
your kids or your parents
if they were around
about where you're at today?
This is temporary?
- I wouldn't say nothing to them 'cause
I wouldn't be able to face them.
- [Mark] There's a lot of shame in it?
- A little bit.
Part of me, yeah.
Has a guilty conscious, but,
part of me is doing this
'cause I want to, I guess.
- [Mark] Do you find there's
something you enjoy about it?
The attention from men or?
- No, just making the money.
- [Mark] Are you concerned about
the future your kids will
have, 'cause you're not around?
- No. I know they're in good hands.
They're gonna do good.
- [Mark] All right, Sweet Pea.
Well, thank you for talking to me.
Good luck.
- [Sweet Pea] Thank you.